somebody sent me a picture where the old
church was which one the one next to the
In-N-Out or no the one where we ended it
okay what happened it looks like a bomb
hit that
place it looks like a bomb hit it like
uh the grass growing in the parking lot
somebody broke down the fence you know
well that was a weird office like they
were all very nice but that like the got
well remember when the lady stole two of
our
buns well to be fair we did leave them
in the we left them I think you walk in
the bathroom you see a bung you leave it
there you don't touch that stuff that's
like bumping into a dead chicken on a
corner in New York City you leave that
there you don't touch that stuff you
don't go to you don't call SVU and check
out the chick you know what I'm saying
you just keep walking